she took scissors so she took scissors
no no
no very sweet she goes to an Albanian
daycare in Brooklyn which is yeah the
best type of daycare we chucking that
people like oh yeah we send our child to
a Chinese daycare so they grow up to
speak Mandarin no send them to the
Albanian daycare and then have a fight
then have a fight all right racist all
right is that what you
think I speak Chinese my daughter's like
yeah I can break kneecaps [__]
that's great may may I inquire as to
your profession Construction
Construction [__] yeah smash the glass
ceiling you
know no see us you know do you do you
cat call women as well do you stand
stand by scaffolding like hey sweetie
you got a great
ass do you cuz that compliment coming
from a woman would mean more I think
you're yeah exactly it depends on the
woman it depends on the woman I mean my
my wife my wife I was with my wife in
Downtown LA when she got catall called
by a guy going past on one of those kind
of bird motorized scooters and and we
went damn girl you got a Fed ass and she
like she she she went and she turned
around then she saw that he was really
handsome and she just
went you never say I've got a fat
ass yes cuz it means something different
when I say it doesn't it amazing wow a
lady construction worker who loves to
watch Chinese and Albanian children
fight that's who knew let's find out who
else is here um you look you know
perfectly respectable clean you know
kind of clean probably what's your dark
secret oh wait do you have a mullet no
it's just the back of your shirt looks a
bit that's all
right do you wish you had a mullet you
look like the kind of guy who would try
it out if you were gen Z rather than
Millennial what what would you do uh I'm
an emergency doctor an emergency doctor
that's really nice so so if there yeah
if there's ever a fight between two
little children
you're called in emergency doctor that's
pretty gnarly I like that so you're not
on call tonight right thank God no oh so
is your job horrendously
depressing people uh make it people make
it interesting who made it interesting
most recently what happened what was it
uh patient confidentiality patient
confidentiality boo look at these these
[__] perverts they want to know we're
not we're not yeah we're not asking yeah
their phones are locked up we're not
asking for names we're just asking for
hypothetical
injuries come on hypothetically
hypothetically oh he get he's on board
with this this is good I love it yes go
people are idiots no what are you Red
stop
it he's joking he was just he was
looking at some naked
ladies People Are People done eating
Jesus okay okay if you don't like
graphic medical stories turn off now yes
go for
it this woman you had a woman who you
keep I just I'll repeat what you say cuz
it's you know you could say it but in a
British accent it will sound more
clever a really large [__] that just
wouldn't come a woman thought she had a
really large [__] that wouldn't come
out so she took scissors so she took
scissors no no
[Applause]
no
I
thought I thought This Woman's lust for
child fights was going to be the depths
of depravity of tonight but no a woman
cutting along the dotted
[Applause]
line thank you for checking that we're
done eating I don't think that really
was enough warning for the the graphic
nature of that that is and I
mean I mean wow all
right we need something to cleanse the
pallet now who do we have any wholesome
individuals in the building who's a
who's a right here right here who who
who are you madam I'm a nurse you're
you're a nurse
no and I've got way more stories Chris I
got way more can you can you balance
this out with something lovely what's
something lovely you did recently and I
don't mean in your job I mean in your
day-to-day life what was a little moment
of wonder that you experienced I came to
New York City you came to New York
City that Applause is not from New
Yorkers every actual New Yorker was
like and I mean yeah okay of course yeah
of course you
are you came so what's the most lovely
thing you've seen in New York since
being here the rat the rats you saw a
lovely
rat is it how
big big describe it in size of a
domestic
animal a small Chihuahua a small
Chihuahua chuah are already pretty small
um and then our New York City visitor
what's your job nurse but what yeah okay
okay and who who you with friends no
well
she threw you guys under the bus right
there but don't worry she'll then also
fix you and um if you feel like you need
a massive poo this is the man that
all okay so you're a lady in
construction who loves babies fighting
you're a nurse who's come to New York
and you're denying having any
relationship with the people you're sat
with you're an emergency Doctor Who has
no social sense of
propriety I mean look what he said is is
something we wish we all could forget
unfortunately this has been building
towards something we're going to we're
going to burn this in your memory uh but
with with a song I think we're going to
we're going to dedicate a song to these
three lovely people about these three
love two lovely PE one lovely person and
two absolute repr
probates so ban do me a favor can you
knock together some type of delicious
beet uh and we'll we'll serve up some
hot bars look at this those fingers the
way they move ah oh we just said a
little faster all right you're testing
me red I'm
[Music]
excited kicking up the tempo yeah we're
testing a lady come to eat our feeling
indigestion she's like hey Doc I feel I
had a large meal so I had to get myself
get some steel two little blades and
then I start snipping unfortunately yeah
I just did a sliping put the Tipping and
then it broke it apart it was incredible
it's like the world biggest fart and you
can see down there now it's just a whole
horrible mix of the red and the brown
and probably black when the Blood starts
to Decay he'd be nodding like yes it
made my day I really love this I was
like super when a lady put scissors up a
pooper I know it doesn't suit you hey
fellows I know you're like why didn't
she just use a dildo to impact it up the
back door the [__] you be giggling at
this just a little bit my nurse at the
back was on offer she's like I'm so glad
mat tourist don't work with that doctor
is this what they do in NYC put scissors
up your backside High KNE where I come
from so tiny yes it depends in my ends I
traveled here but these are my friends
who the [__] are you why you at my table
you're a strange person mentally
unstable what you're talking about Sarah
we your bestie since high school no I've
never heard you before but I rule when
it comes to nursing when I'm on the
subway I saw a rat so small today a
Sunday it was down there I would rather
that it was larger but sadly size of a
Chihuahua the smallest little rat that
exists in the system usually they're fat
so blissfully miss them if you see a rat
that's bloated you pick up your scalp
all your scissors and you go for it
you're like stab stab I'm the brand new
rats are like Teenage mja Turtles are
the last thing got my lady yes what
she's like spending all day on the
building site like oh pretty lady with
the large breasts I would like to see
you undressed to the test she be so
lovely construction lady crazy cuz at
night she dreams of fighting babies not
her versus them that would be unfair but
just a little pair of the toddlers with
care they come up there they're like
fight please punch punch one's Albanian
and one's Chinese who would win well
technically the Chinese would there's
like 1.4 billion there's more understood
and all the blood gets cleaned up by my
guy and she leaves New York City on a
massive bloody
height
you guys are lovely my name is Chris
Turner I will see you guys around
sometime cheers
bye